[Music]
what is going on everybody and welcome
to part three of the starcraft 2 ai
tutorials in this video what we're going
to do is basically build on the last one
so we built a little bit of a defense um
but not probably not going to be able to
win
with purely a defense i mean there's a
possibility i suppose maybe there's some
sort of strategy where
you could expand really fast uh and
exhaust all of the resources faster than
your opponent and then also build up
these like canon defenses or something
and then win that way maybe i don't know
but that's not where we're gonna be
doing today
so we're gonna try to build these void
ray units now the void ray unit is a
pretty good i think general purpose
all-around unit uh and that is this
little guy right here it's like a flying
unit and it shoots a laser beam so i
think it looks cool it seems pretty
general purpose apparently it is not
super strong i think it's against tehran
maybe it's generally yes so it's
generally not used due to the standard
composition of the tehran being very
strong against it
is what they say so probably if you're
trying to make a really good strategy
your strategy is actually going to vary
based on you'd have a strategy for
versus tehran a strategy versus protoss
strategy versus zerg and all that for
now we're going to keep it all super
generic
but just keep that in mind that it can
vary
so
in order to have that unit let me pull
this back over actually
in order to have that unit we do need a
nexus to exist we need to then build a
gateway we then need to build a
cybernetics core we then need to build a
stargate and then we can build the void
ray the other thing to note is in order
to build that stargate we need this
vespine gas we have not collected any
gas either so we need to do quite a bit
so let's go ahead and minimize this and
we will start by building the
assimilators now this might vary by
different maps i've only recently been
playing this same exact map
on this map it's clear there are two gas
locations and the assimilator is this
thing that you build on top of the gas
spot so
since there's two of them we want to
build two of them as we expand out it's
possible we want to build more there's
probably a way to do like a dynamic
check to see like how many of these are
within some range of where you are um so
or or even better just see like
is there an open one or something like
that there's probably a way for that i
don't know it yet so instead we're just
gonna build two
i know there are two so we will build
two
um so
uh where we're gonna do that is we want
all of our pylons first
once we have pylons we then want to
build the assimilators uh it might be
the case that after maybe this first
pylon we would build an assimilator and
then build these subsequent pylons
i actually can't i'm not really sure i
in my notes i have built it after the
pylons i don't believe i've actually
tested this um i'm curious i think on
this one i will build it here i kind of
think that it might make more sense you
just need that one pylon right uh
i i don't know i
i okay i'm gonna i'll build it i'll
build it over here
i really don't know i don't know which
one's smarter um i almost kind of want
to build like two more pylons and then
there's some i don't know it doesn't i
don't know but comment below if you have
any opinion on the matter you're
probably already worth commenting if you
did have an opinion on the matter so
so what i'm going to say is down here
we'll say elif self dot structures
and in this case again our good old unit
type id that needs to be like shortened
to like
never mind
the shortened version is worse i'm not
going to say it uh so
uh dot assimilator so if elif self dot
structures assimilator dot amount is
less than or equal to one
if i'm still stuck on how i wanted to
shorten this but anyways uh if we have
less than or equal to one which means
um
if we have one or less so we want to
build up to two of these
maybe it should be less than two i just
feel like that doesn't i feel like less
than two makes a little more sense
going against my notes
so if we have less than two what we want
to do is we want to say
um
essentially this also doesn't really
make much sense for my uh
we're going to say vespines equals
self.vest being underscore geyser
dot closer underscore than
um
15 to
our nexus
so our nexus is already defined so in my
in my code i'm actually iterating over
nexuses and i don't really i don't see a
need for that um maybe that'll bite me
in the in the rear later but i don't
think it will so for vest being in vest
beans we expect that we'll have two
um
i wonder if like maybe i'm not going to
change this much of the code but yeah i
think in this case
you would just
um
[Music]
i don't know like you would just count
these and then that's how many you would
build i think it would be the smarter
play here but for now we'll just we'll
just do this so what we're going to say
is if uh self dot
can
afford so if we can afford um and in
fact i'm just going to copy this for now
so if we can afford an assimilator and
not
self.already underscore pending
an assimilator
so if all that is the case then we will
go ahead and
await self.build
an assimilator
and we'll build it on that vespine
location
okay so that will build us
to assimilators so the assimilators will
start accruing gas for us hopefully at
this point so then we will build the
forge
and then the photon cannons so we'll let
those
we would probably want to have some base
defense pretty quickly so
we'll let those happen and then after
those that's where we will start
building the required structures i part
of me also like i wonder if there's like
a good way
like the three
kind of want to like here's what i'm
going to do i think i think i could just
like cycle this code like do a for loop
or something
um
near structures
pylon
yeah so so this is the code i'm actually
you don't need to copy and paste this
but this is the this is the code from
the tutorial
and i think i kind of want to clean it
up a little bit so
so in this case this is like three bits
of code that are basically identical
it's just for different unit type ids so
um
so i think what i will i'm going to
change this to on the fly hopefully i
don't regret this
is we want to build the following three
buildings so we want a gateway we want a
cybernetics core
and then we want a stargate so the
stargate is what builds the void rays
so we want these three buildings we want
them in that row
right um so
l if um
can you have an l if and i guess that's
the prob the problem is
i want to cycle over these buildings but
i also i need it to be
this like elif statement
so building so
for
hmm how do i do this
uh
i'm probably going to regret doing this
so for
be in buildings
um i guess we'll break if we build if we
actually build it
and then that way we have time to like
build the next building because the
buildings have to exist in this order
we'll try this and oh if this breaks
then i'll figure it out so 4b in
buildings
um
and in fact we'll write this out just
keep it clear so for b in buildings
what i want to do
is
alif so
if
not
um
self i'll write this out at least once
self dot structures
if not self touch structures
dude
so if we don't have that building
then really what we're trying to do is
if self dot can afford
that building
then we will await
self.build
that building
near uh and it will be near
um
yeah near a pylon closest to the nexus
um and in fact don't i already have that
code
yes we do so here
so i'm going to copy and paste from the
forge down to here
that so if not
so we will build
can i just like toss a break there
because we have to wait for that
building to build i think
and then we also have questions about
pendings and all that
i'm not really sure i like this so if
this doesn't work i would just you would
just copy and paste this code and then
copy and paste these things in there i'm
not really sure this is gonna work
i'm already regretting it and i have no
idea if this is gonna work or not but
we'll comment this out cool
for building a buildings blah blah blah
if we can then we break it that should
be fine we break out of that loop
um
yeah let's just see if that runs
uh i already feel the pangs of regret
and we haven't even like what if it
works it could be good it could be good
uh make this a little smaller
so again the other thing is we're not
checking about like already pendings and
all this kind of stuff so we might wind
up with like multiples of buildings so
it's possible we would want to check for
that
um but
one step at a time here
so we have our pylons coming in we have
so fast we have our gateway built these
are assimilators this is our forge that
already came up boom we already have our
star gate
man that's it's so quick when uh when
the little ai does it for you huh so in
this case we have two
i'm not even sure what happened
i guess did we get attacked
and this got like disabled or are we
we don't have enough
pylons maybe to power this
i honestly have no idea
like this guy seems to probably be out
of the range of any pylon maybe is that
the problem
someone probably comment below tell me i
think that's what's wrong is that pylon
is actually
so at least i i think the logic was
actually
halfway decent um i'm going to let that
stand for now i think we can make this a
little more complicated later
we could also throw in the pending thing
um
we just do this
copy that
if not
self dot
for building if
so if not
no matter what i think we're going to
want to break here
because if we if that gets triggered we
want to break no matter what if not
that and then we'll also say and
self dot already pending
um
building
equals zero so
as long as
those two things are true but if that's
not true right if it is pending we still
can't build the next building so we're
still going to break um
might not even be necessary because i
don't i just don't we can't build it
anyways we might not need that there at
all but i'm gonna have it there for now
okay so
once we have all of those things like we
at least saw we did get to the point
where we could um
continue this i also kind of want to
rather than
building it near this like we could keep
doing that and building towards the
enemy but we i swear what we just saw
was
was the problem so maybe this should be
um
positioned i don't know towards and then
almost like nexus or something we might
want to pass nexus there i i'm not
really sure but i i think it was
probably that was the problem um i could
be mistaken again i'm an sc2
dummy so so anyway um i think
the next thing that we're going to add
here is
once we know
our nexus outside of or really
of utmost importance is we want to build
the void ray unit
so
what we're going to ask here is if
if self dot
structures
uh cell structures i wonder if that's
true like i wonder if is it should it be
self.structures or
where are our
hmm i don't i'm not sure if southside
structure is the right right uh thing to
use there but anyways i'll continue
using it uh unit type id dot void ray
dot amount is less than if we have less
than 10
and we can self or and self dot can
afford so if we can afford that void ray
in effect give me this
we're learning we're learning if we can
afford that floyd ray then what do we
want to do well we're going to say
um
i'm not sure if i really want to say
stargate um
eventually you might
i don't know what i want to say here i
think eventually you might have multiple
stargates like as things progress and as
you come up against harder enemies
chances are as time goes on you'll wind
up with multiple stargates so if you
have multiple targets you can produce
produce these like void rays faster so
i guess i'm gonna leave it this way but
right now we just have one but anyways
so for sg for stargate in
self.structures
self.structures in this case it's unit
type id dot and then all caps stargate
dot ready
also dot idle so if they're not already
building a void ray no reason to like if
you're playing by hand
it could make sense to like pending up a
few of these things but um
in the case of an ai why waste it um
it's not necessary so if self dot can
afford um
then i already yeah
i'm finding all kinds of problems i'm
improving my code
um
on the second pass so we don't need to
ask if we can afford so we're just going
to say sg.train
and we'll train that void right
cool so we get void rays hopefully
um we could run it and double check to
make sure that works but i'll go ahead
and add in the attack
so
the attack
does the attack require
a nexus
i'm going to say no
and in fact if we don't have a nexus we
really want to attack like that's our
last hope so so um i think our attack
should occur outside of this if
statement so if we don't have a nexus
uh we'll basically run this else let's
try to expand to a nexus
but outside of all of that
we then have because that's kind of like
all those lifts and stuff that's for our
um building and stuff like that but
outside of that our attacking units
probably will have an entirely different
logic so
for now what i want to start to say is
that we're just going to come out here
and then we're going to ask if self dot
units
void ray dot amount is greater than or
equal to
uh three so if we have
uh
essentially four or actually greater
than or equal three or more if we have
three or more void rays
we're going to attack i think i've
filmed too many this is my third in a
row for the day and um clearly i am at
my max so
so uh if we have three or more void rays
then essentially we have um
three
[Music]
three bits of information let me see if
i can pull this up
so here from the github documentation i
found this following section and
basically here
it's a list of basically information
that's available about the game that you
have access to
so
you can find this is just your resource
and supply information you can find some
information about your own units
and then you also can
so i guess self.units your units
includes larva and words i'm still
wondering about the pending unit thing
units
software structures units your
structures including so anyways i'm not
sure it does a void ray is that really
included in the self.structures
anyway
um
coming down here other information about
you and your bot so you get some stuff
here um
information about the enemy here we go
this is what i was looking for um so
you know like sometimes there are there
like if you're one of your units spots
one of the enemy units this becomes
available to you so this would be
self.enemy units
so this would be just anything that
you've actually seen um same thing with
enemy structures so if you happen to see
one of the enemy structures it would be
included in this
and then finally the enemy start
location
you are privy to this information as
well at this you know this is part of
your game information you can also query
your enemies race so again this would be
you might want to query that to
determine what is what is the logic that
you're going to be using we're not we're
not that advanced
at least i'm not but clearly i think
that is a probably one of the next early
steps that you would take so coming back
over here essentially we need to
determine what will be the order of
things that we want to attack so
going to the enemy start location means
you've run out of all your other
possibilities i think
so then you just have to decide do we
want to attack enemy units or enemy
buildings first and i think we want to
go for enemy
units first then buildings then go to
the start location so that's what i'm
going to code in
but there could be all kinds of far more
advanced logic so you know enemy units
at your base are more important than
just like any of the enemy units for
example so um for now i'm going to keep
it super simple but just obviously keep
that in mind
so
uh if
so if we have
uh greater than or equal to three void
rays we're gonna say if self dot enemy
unit so do we have any enemy units that
we are aware of for
vr so void ray in self.units
and we are going to use this i don't
know if i still have this copy and
pasted so i'll just copy
paste
um
if any of them are idle what we're going
to say is take that void ray and we will
attack and then we're just going to
attack a random dot choice
from self.enemy units again this should
get far more complicated than that
that's a very rudimentary way of
choosing who to attack
but
at least for now that will that will
suffice i think
so
if we don't know about any any any enemy
units elif self.enemy structures do we
know about any enemy structures if we do
we're going to just i'm just going to
copy and paste this boom
um self dot enemy structures
blah blah
boom
wow why
okay cool
um so then we'll check for enemy
structures and then if all else fails
else
we are going to for void ray in our void
rays that are idle we want to attack
um it's not going to be a random choice
it will just be self dot enemy start
locations
zero we will attack that spot
okay i think
i think we're good let's go ahead and
see what if anything i screwed up
okay we're off to a pretty good start i
still think i'm going to i kind of want
to adjust those pylons i really think
that's kind of screwing us a little bit
like i think we
you can i think for the most part it's
fine but it seems like we can get
unlucky there
and probably run into trouble
so it looks like we actually yeah one of
our void rays up they're already going
to the enemy
we are already attacking them um
it looks like they're doing okay so in
this case we have four void rays looks
like they want to surrender uh we do not
accept sorry
we're gonna take that victory
yeah there will be no surrender um okay
so we definitely won within 1500 frames
actually that was really quick and i
don't know if you caught that but at the
beginning of that match we actually our
void rays were actually used in the
defense they attacked us early and we
happened to have some at least one void
ray i happened i saw the cool laser so
so uh so yeah you can use them either
for attack or defense and again
in this case
um in our code we're not actually
defending like if if you are under
attack we might as well use our void
rays for defense immediately right like
we don't need to have four of them so
there's just there's so much that we
could do and i think if they get
attacked they will just automatically
defend probably um i don't know that for
sure but anyway um so yeah we can see
we've got two void rays three void rays
probably very soon boom they're off to
attack the enemy but we're actually
under attack right now that's not good
there we got another void ray at least
that was good and then coming down here
we are
destroying
and already we've we've got a
potential surrender and a victory this
time victory again within about 1500
frames so that is race zerg uh let's
check out race protoss let's see how we
do against
essentially ourselves
let's run that again
so we've got our pylons up yeah i don't
really see any benefit for the pylons to
be over there but i'd hate for the
pylons to be like getting in the way of
stuff so i don't really know
so we already have a void ray up we got
two void rays up let's go
off to attack the enemy
pretty quick it looks like
yeah this is not going well for them
[Music]
it does seem like maybe it's go taking a
little longer but it's hard to say we
have a lot of way to raise there
um
okay now they're surrendering oh and we
have we have victory uh what was that so
1800 frames instead of 1500
um okay so we are we are definitely
winning against protoss and zerg
on hard difficulty already so um
that's pretty good uh but apparently we
are weak against tehran so let's go
ahead and save that
and let's run against tehran and see how
we do okay
we are off i still kind of want to i
don't know how exactly i want to fix
those pylons but
i think they should just be
probably all at the base i just i would
hate to like stuff ourselves in but i
guess it really doesn't matter like we
don't actually ever need to leave
our base oh looks like we've already
initiated an attack
uh i think we just died
i think we got stopped
i'm not really sure
uh now that we're flying back oh maybe
we just saw are they flying back to our
base or what is going on there
not enough psi so we need more pylon so
i guess we okay so yeah we've run out of
space i guess our pylons
oh it's not looking oh
oh no
uh i think we're gonna lose this fight
um yeah there's no way that we're gonna
win oh goodness oh goodness
wow what is their little flying flying
thing yeah we've we have lost
we have lost
uh so sad so sad so they at least beat
us once we put up a good fight that was
a long fight
um
[Music]
2400 frames it looks like so not a
terrible fight come on void rays let's
go
okay we're off to attack hopefully we
don't just die immediately that's what
our problem was last time was yeah we
just got conquered immediately
wow their army is so like their people
are like they have just like such a big
army and immediately
um it's a little rough it's a little
rough
[Music]
very sad very sad
so yeah we probably should limit our
workers to maybe
um maybe 24 should be the limit of our
workers
um
the other thing i i think i want to do
is for our pylons
near
near nexus
near
near this
um i kind of want to like
i don't know how i want to do this i
think i might just say near nexus
but hopefully we don't block off our
nexus but what if i just uh near near
near
near nexus save that i already forgot
what was the other thing i wanted to do
i can't remember what there was one more
thing i wanted to do and i can't
remember it so if nexus is idle and we
can afford a probe we want to leave room
to always build more void rays
so if nexus is idle and we can afford a
probe
and we will add
um
a
supply
remaining is going to be equal to
self.supply
cap so how many total could we have
minus self.supply
used
and that will give us oh
do we really have a self dot
self.supply left
we might not we might not be
we can't speak we might not need to be
using that like little calculation
so i'm going to use that for now but i i
didn't see that before in the
documentation but okay
um and um
[Music]
supply remaining is greater than four so
basically what we're doing here is um
[Music]
as long as we have four this gives us
enough room to build another void ray
um i think i like that so we'll save
that let's go ahead and
let's run that we've made a couple of
changes here i am curious because we
were seeing that we were like running
out of space and i think that was our
problem so we weren't able to we really
want a prior if we can build a void ray
we definitely want to build a void ray
over building uh more of those like
probes we don't want them anymore so um
so yeah
off to a good start
where's our stargate
it looks like we're okay with those
pylons oh i think we're okay like i
don't think it's actually blocking
anything so you just wouldn't want to
like slow anything down by having them
but i think we're all right okay so we
did we survived at least an attack
now we're attacking them we are
consistently sending you can even see we
are sending more void rays into the
attack
they have
they have surrendered
[Laughter]
see ya
sit down
yeah it feels good um okay let's try
that again maybe we got lucky maybe that
was good so so
i think before we would have been unable
to continue sending reinforcement void
raise um because we were filling up our
um
filling up our supply with with uh
probes
i think that was our problem i think
probably over time you would want to
like
maybe maybe limit the probes like 24 per
nexus or something like that at max
because but you are using probes to like
build buildings so i don't really know
again i'm not a starcraft 2 pro
really not
um but yeah we'll see so last time they
did attack us around this point they did
not this time though so we go in for the
attack we did not make it oh
okay how's our supply so we do
we are leaving room but now we have no
room oh wait i guess we built more void
rights okay they're in for the attack
okay we are not i don't think we'll win
this one because we're sending too small
of a force
uh in for the attack on these guys i
think that's our problem
we did pretty good i mean we did good
and we we clearly can beat them we did
beat them once i should i sort of closed
out the tutorial at the defeat and said
yeah we did it 100 victory
[Laughter]
um
you know we might want to have more than
three
for uh
for attacking them maybe greater than or
equal to five i don't really know
um i'm not really sure i can't really
decide and then maybe what we'll do
supply routine what if we do like eight
there i wonder if maybe that would help
just to make more room i'm not sure i
really don't know yeah i think we build
pylons at a rate that is so fast that we
could leave plenty of room for void rays
so we might even we might even leave
even more room that i've done
so we have the oh we got a good amount
okay they just attacked us but we've got
plenty of void rays i think we're good
we're good beautiful
beautiful
soon maybe we want to we might also want
to build two of these uh stargates like
where's our
did we limit i think we limited we made
stargates um
i think i know what our problem was
[Laughter]
so we needed five and five would i think
we need more more supply okay i think i
know what i've done so maybe we'll
change this back um
to three
okay one more time
okay we're off to a pretty good start
we've got a good i think initial defense
set up
uh we are going in for a very early
attack there
doing pretty well
we should be sent it yet we got another
reinforcements coming in very good
we are at maximum
i guess we need to have a couple void
rays die in order to make more at this
point how many do we have we have five
void rays at this point
we might maybe next time we'd leave more
room
but it looks like we are definitely
victorious here
they keep coming in that's cute um
i guess because we got attacked and then
we'll come over here okie dokie
so probably we would need some code that
like hunts out the rest of the enemies
because yeah we're obviously having a
hard time finding where they are okay
here we go hopefully we'll finish the
game at this point
they do want to surrender um i don't
know how to hit yes
i feel like we have to like fly these
guys around to figure out where the heck
where the heck is the enemy
here
i'm just gonna keep clicking around till
we find him was it here yep there we go
man where else are these guys
wait did we just lose
i think we might lose oh no how can we
say i want to hit accept yes now i think
we just lost all our void rays
i'm saying we won
i don't know how i don't know how to
accept the victory oh man that was funny
looks like we probably have a victory on
our hands here
so yeah anyways okay clearly like tehran
is a little harder to defeat but still
very much doable with void rays and at
least for me
um
okay we won again so at least for me
there there's obviously so much more
logic that needs to be
invoked here and there's something
screwy happening with like our our
probes versus our void rays and all that
kind of stuff so this needs to be
cleaned up for sure but i think for now
that's a pretty good start to
to um to some starcraft 2 logic
and defeating apparently the hard terron
i don't know if that's like har if
that's supposed to be like hard for
using starcraft 2 ai or if that's
supposed to be like hard versus a
a player i'm not really sure because
that seemed like that was not very hard
so anyways feel free to comment below um
anyways i think i'll stop it here this
is already quite long uh if you've got
questions comments concerns or
suggestions or whatever feel free to
leave those below otherwise i will see
you all in another video
you